bonjour chers télénautes bonjour chers
et loi encore une émission de diagonale
sont consacrés aux pions c'est ce sont
des fins de parties qui apparemment
semble simple mais il faut les connaître
sur le bout des doigts
alors aujourd'hui vas tu nous montres et
oui et alors la dernière fois nous avons
vu les finales d'options simple
c'est-à-dire wépion contreras est-ce que
c'est gagnant est ce que c'est nul il y
avait diverses cas différents cas donc
là vous avez bien sûr l'occasion de
revenir voir cette première étape des
finales d'options dans les différents
diagonale les finales donc un pion suffi
au roi tu rencontreras s gagnant s nul
vous pouvez tout savoir en revenant dans
les différer maintenant plus compliqué
c'est dire qu'on va de s'attaquer au
final option complexe avec plusieurs
cures d'accord alors là aujourd'hui tu
va nous montrer une arme terrible en
finale de pioncer le pion passé éloigné
voile alors chante pas s'éloigner
il est très fort pourquoi hein parce que
c'est un pion passé alors qu'ils ont
passé c'est à dire qu'il n'a plus
d'opposants devant lui et donc que le
chemin est tout tracé il n'a plus qu'a
avancé et il n'a pas de pions adverse
sur son passage
la seule chose qui peut donc arrêter un
pour passer en finale deux pions c'est
le roi alors maintenant j'en passe et
éloignées c'est mieux pourquoi
et bien pour une raison très simple
c'est que le pion fait simplement
diversion c'est à dire que il est loin
et c'est forcément le roi qui va venir
le chercher
et pendant ce temps là donc quand le roi
va dépendre des temps et des temps pour
aller chercher le pion qui sera passée
éloigné notre droit à nous lui il va
pouvoir se ruer dans les brancards est
allé manger tous les pions adverse de
l'autre côté bon alors je crois que déjà
il ya la position de base qu'il faut
connaître un on va là on va la regarder
vous avez deux rois sur l'échiquier qui
sont en opposition d'un côté de
l'échiquier 1 sur les cases à 2 à 4 et
vous avez un pion de l'autre côté le
champion a shark et comment il faut
faire ici alors nous avions déjà vu
cette position dans le temps la leçon
précédente
effectivement un lien actions passées là
qui est éloigné l'option est passé il
n'a pas d'opposants il est également
éloigné puisqu'il est très loin des rois
alors c'est au noir de jouer il joue
comme premier coup un roi p 5
très logique donc on essaye de courir
vers le pion pour l'empêcher d'aller à
dame
leroy court vers le pion met donc le
pion avance bien entendu 2,4 on rappelle
que le plus fort peu avancé de deux
cases même à la fin de la partie
bah quand il est sur sa case départ
c'est quand il est sur la case de départ
le pion à vence est là donc on
s'aperçoit on va refaire le carré du
pion c'est ce qu'on avait expliqué la
dernière fois c'est à dire qu'on forme
une sorte de carré voilà vous voyez vous
tracez une diagonale
ensuite à partir de là vous remonter
jusqu'à la hauteur du pion et là nous
avons le car et c'est à dire que si le
roi noir
enfin le roi et demi au pire arrive à se
mettre dans ces cases verte dans ce
réseau de case verte
eh bien il va stopper le pion il va
l'arrêter il va même le manger d'accord
alors pour tirer le carré on prend la
diagonale qui part du pion marque du
pion et ensuite et on forme le car est
bon donc ici on s'aperçoit très vite que
le roi n'est pas dedans donc forcément
le plus on va aller tout seul adam
c'est un exemple le pion et en paix ces
personnes ne l'arrête à par le roi le
roi n'étant pas dans le carré il est
donc trop loin et vous s'aperçoit que dd
est pas loin
il est à l'arrêt donc qu'est ce qu'on
fait en fait dames ont fait promotion
dame promotionnaires encore une fois on
a le choix entre de choisir une dame un
cavalier un fou une tour mais on prend
évidemment la dame puisque après on a
une finale technique roi et dames contre
roye qu'on a déjà vu oui et que donc je
vous répète c'est important que vous
pouvez retrouver dans différé sur canal
web sur diagonale un vous cliquez vous
avez un problème technique et vous
revoyez ces finales et foulée connaître
tous les joueurs n'y a pas besoin d'être
grand maître nip mettre tous les joueurs
de compétition connaît ça par coeur pour
atteindre votre roi c'est effectivement
la finale de base donc ici une fois que
vous avez fait dame
vous savez battait donc s'est terminé
alors on revoit une dernière fois cette
position de départ on voit que dans
cette position le petit l'option blanc
h2 qui est ici vers il est passé il est
éloigné et donc il suffit tout seul à
gagner la partie
donc on va maintenant passer un deuxième
exemple bac plus complexe oui assez
simple à cet exemple là était simple on
comprend qu'il faut le pion de allait
foncer vers la dame alors là
effectivement c'est un peu plus
compliqué parce que dia des pions en
plus et ils sont pas là que pour décorer
voilà
il y a donc une grosse différence il ya
ça alors rappelons nous on l'a vu dans
la leçon de la dernière fois sur le
thème un pion suffit que cette formation
là si on enlève les pions qui sont au
vert c'est à dire si on laisse que les
pièces rouges
cette pollution est nul c'est le fameux
pions h ou pas le pion qui est donc sur
le côté ne gagne pratiquement jamais
spécialement quand le roi et demi est
proche donc là ça serait tout simplement
nul s'il n'y avait pas ces pions en
verre de l'autre côté de l'échiquier
voilà et c'est là justement que tout
passe est éloigné va faire sa diversion
alors la méthode là on va être
didactique la méthode c'est de d'abord
prendre le position rendirent à demi
mots je sais que tu vas revenir là
dessus parce que c'est fondamental mais
un petit mot sur l'opposition
un petit mot sur l'opposition c'est donc
les fameux roi on met souvent en face
durant et demi voilà et on gagne du
terrain puisqu'il est obligé de faire
des concessions
alors ici le premier coup blanc et un
roi f4 est là on prend l'opposition
effectivement on se met face au roi et
demi l'idée dans cette finale c'est très
simple c'est que là le roi noir
maintenant et dans 1 devant un curieux
dilemme est ce qu'il faut aller prendre
le pion blanc qui est en h4 le pion
blanquier tout seul ici ouais
ou est ce qu'il faut aller défendre son
pion ici en b 6
le roi ne sais pas trop il va pas
pouvoir et ne pourra pas faire les deux
voilà c'est là la clé de l'énigme dont
considérons dans un premier temps qu'il
va essayer de manger le thon blanc qu'il
est un homme elle est arrêtée le pont
blanc alors là le côté blanc c'est très
simple le pion là peut être sacrifiée
sacrifier tout simplement il fait
diversion et nous avec notre roi on
fonce de l'autre côté
donc là on prend à contre-pied laurent
noir bien manger de pions mais là on
s'aperçoit qu'il est quand même très
très en retard il est sérieusement en
retard puisque nous on continue notre
marche vers les pions il revient il
essaie de revenir tout au moins on prend
le premier pion il revient encore et on
prend encore un pion et là c'est une
finale très très simple à gagner
pourquoi et bien la méthode la plus
simple pour gagner cette finale on fait
abstraction du pion b3 on en a pas
besoin
on amène le roi là il contrôle déjà ces
trois cases là et on va avancer notre
pions vaches bon là c'est gagné mais ça
c'est bon je crois que ton image de
contre-pied c'est exactement comme au
foot au tennis à qu'on fait croire qu'on
va d'un côté le piote plus le pion pas
s'éloigner
oblige le roi d'aller d'un côté et on
passe de l'autre on a un petit coup de
rein il n'y a rien à faire donc c'est ça
on insiste là-dessus c'est vraiment très
important ici le pion pas s'éloigner va
obliger le roi noir 2 de s'occuper de
lui parce que c'est une menace le niveau
budget que le pion un pion passé c'était
un assassin un assassin potentiel tirkel
faut le il faut essayer de le tenir en
respect le problème c'est que s'il tient
en respect il peut pas les défendre les
pauvres pions donc voyons une deuxième
possibilité pour les noirs c'est la
croix y aller doucement dans cette
position une nouvelle possibilité c'est
à dire qu'il dit je ne vais pas arrêter
le jeu ne bouge pas je vais aller
défendre les miens c'est un fils joue
comme ça possibilité voilà il se dit je
vais aller défendre les pions alors dans
ce cas là il suffit de pousser un peu
plus la diversion voilà on avance notre
pions pourquoi pas donc là par contre il
peut pas sortir du carré en revoyant le
carré encore une fois voilà le carré
étant là il est obligé la salade un
sinon le pion par saddam
voilà donc le roi doit rester donc il
peut pas aller sur la case une quatre
pieds j'ai ici serait la case des six
donc le ballet dessus donc il
reviendrait logiquement réussite et là
on repart tout simplement là ils
essayent de rester en classe a il a
finalement au centre
j'ai tout essayé de rester là mais là là
on continuerait on renverra la diversion
alors là le cariste réduit 1 kg de
rentrer dans le car est là il faut
qu'ils rentrent dans le carré c'est à
dire qu'il reviendrait c'est par exemple
sur lesquels là et là il est obligé de
lâcher les cases et là ils lâchent la
faire voilà va les manger c'est
d'options voilà donc ça c'est revenons
sur la pression de départ une position
très simple
les blancs ont un pion hcap qui est un
pion passé éloigné on le redira jamais
assez c'est exactement la définition de
solutions
de l'autre côté il ya des pions qui se
tiennent en vis-à-vis et là tout
simplement ont fait diversion
on va d'un côté avec le roi attaqué les
deux ans et demi de l'autre côté on
avance notre passé est tout simplement
ça suffit pour gagner donc alors je
reviens aussi pour être plus générale
c'est un pion tu nous l'a dit une leur
redit un pion souffre souvent suffit
pour gagner
bon il ya quelques cas nul mais alors
quand il ya deux pions d'avancé a gagné
2 95%
un moyen là qu'est ce que c'est on l'a
vu c'est
vous inquiétez pas faut simplement aller
doucement regarder quand même que ces
finales qui sont simples demandes de la
méthode c'est à dire qu'il faut quand
même y aller doucement bien faire trôner
souffler un peu comme blue souffler on a
vu dans le stress un faut savoir aussi
qu'en compétition dans le stress parfois
ça se passe nous sauve ou trois quatre
heures de jeu 5 heures de jeu on peut se
fatiguer donc il faut aller doucement
vous savez que là vous êtes gagnant donc
vous prenez votre temps oui oui non
c'est clair en tout cas dans une finale
option il faut pas jouer au coup par
coup
ça c'est un grand principe élaborer
votre plan travailler tranquillement vos
stratégies dites vous qu'il ya un pion
passé qui va aller là le roi qui valait
de l'autre côté tout ça très calmement
une fois qu'on a trouvé le plan le plan
de gains qui est ici unis version bête
et méchant c'est à dire on de menace à
la fois et ne peut pas parler d'eux une
fois qu'on a bien trouvé ce plan est
bien là on commence à jouer les coups on
commence à se concentrer sur les coûts
donc là je pense que cet exemple est
assez clair vous l'aurez un jour vous
aurez peut-être pas exactement cette
position mais vous allez retrouver ça il
faut savoir que ça arrive souvent vous
avez bien joué le parti vous avez un
pion davance font faire quelque chose
oui ici ici voilà un curieux dilemme si
les pions côté gauche de l'échiquier
n'était pas là ça serait complètement
nul le fait est qu'ils sont là et donc
il nous permet de faire cette diversion
et de gagner la partie
alors un petit troisième exemple alors
oui puis on monte en difficulté un cerf
quand on a vu alors là ça devient déjà
un peu plus compliqué alors là ça
devient un peu atypique même je dirais
un peu atypique c'est à dire que d'abord
lots a voulu absolument se mais c'est
bien c'est bien d'abord on est à égalité
matérielle comptons le matériel il faut
toujours dire ça aux échecs
ça va vous sembler un petit peu
fastidieux mais après ça devient presque
un réflexe on compte toujours le
matériel ici vous avez deux pions blancs
contre deux pions noirs donc a priori il
ya une relative égalité vous pouvez le
savoir mais meilleur il ya une grosse
différence
enfin chaque camp adoption passé les
noirs ont d'options passé ici passent et
toujours dans le sens où il n'y a pas de
pions blancs pour les arrêter et les
blancs ont d'options passé ici donc on
va me dire quelle est la différence
et bien tout simplement les tons noirs
ils sont groupés alors que les
turbulences on explique t splitté
ou disons éloignés les uns des autres
donc tout ça va entraîner un mais moi je
la jette embêter un petit peu c'est à
dire que souvent
dans le début de partie dans le milieu
de partie on dit vaut mieux couper ses
pions c'est mieux quand de psion sont
liés et seat est donc en finale c'est
pas vrai alors donc là je les
expressions et stratégie générale
oui une explication simple c'est que
vous voyez que les deux options qui sont
là se défendre mutuellement et ça c'est
une bonne chose
c'est à dire qu'il suffit de défendre
celui qui est là l'option b 4 il y en a
qu'un seul à défendre puisque lui-même
défend l'autre ça c'est l'avantagé
d'être regroupé les plus éloignés
effectivement ne se défendent pas entre
eux voilà alors qu'est ce qui se passe
en milieu de jeu il ya des pièces qui
ont des portées très longue qui vont
très vite d'un bout à l'autre de
l'échiquier donc là pour eux les pions
passé douaniers c'est de la rigolade
c'est à dire qu'ils vont très très vite
d'un bout à l'autre de l'échiquier donc
ya pas de problème ils arrêtent le pion
sur la caisse de promotion où ils
veulent donc la priorité à la défense
il faut défendre ses pions en revanche
quand il n'ya plus clairoix qui est une
pièce quand même assez lente puisque
elle se déplace que d'une case à la fois
là la priorité est à la diversification
d'accord donc les deux pions là ne font
pas une menace vraiment diversifié mais
elle n'arrive pas à dominer icône avis
contrôler le roi semble dominer voilà
pour le roi sans le dominer c'est
exactement ce à dire que le roi là ne
peut pas prendre ce pion oui alors
pourquoi puisque à ce moment-là il
sortirait du carré de l'autre pions le
car est de le pion à 3 d'accord qui est
ici donc si droit se met sur la case
rouge qui est toujours donc disons le
gaz piégé d'accord à ce moment là le
pion irait adam d'ailleurs on peut on
peut peut-être le montrer voilà ouais
donc nos rois prendre pions
malheureusement assez ça d'accord
malheureusement le pion à 11 à la main
dans le cul avancées y va
le moins d'un an mais sa graine alors ça
ça fait rien c'est ce que la dame est
une pièce à longue portée en cas comment
on fait l'arrêt manger ton action il
faut manger tous les pions il faut
commencer par manger nous mangent les
pions on se met dans notre finale
thématique moi c'est qu'on connaît bien
on a déjà vu au royaume contre droit et
au matin donc dans cette position là
effectivement les blancs ne peuvent pas
prendre le tchèque ne peuvent pas
progresser de ce côté-là l'afrique est
alors maintenant quand tu es noir qu'est
ce qui se passe puisque la l'échiquier
vraiment c'est pareil on connaît le roi
plan ne peut pas aller du côté drôle de
chéquiers et inversement
qu'est ce qui se passe on adoption passé
il va falloir en avance et enfin les
avancées de l'accord donc si on ne va
pas d'armes on ne gagnera pas on va donc
là alors une proposition c'est le coup
h5 donc un point qui donne le plus
éloigné un point ap ap ap ap ap le
maître loin loin très loin le renoir
éloigner le roi noir au maximum très
logiquement le roi noir vient angers 5
il veut essayer de l'arrêter de le
manger la menace est sérieuse menace est
de prendre le pion d'accord
malheureusement il y a le deuxième pion
la deuxième diversion qui montante des 5
1 qui monte sur cette case là une sorte
il ya un chasseur mais il ya de la part
de ces ça il ya deux lapins y avait donc
là on reforme le carré de ce pion et on
voit tout de suite que le pion h5 il est
en dehors du cac a cédé à que si
maintenant le roi noir pampillon l'autre
est inarrêtable
mais voilà l'eau dont kim on peut le
regarder ouais 3.5 est une possibilité
il y aurait des six
voilà le roi mon temps j'ai six des sept
balles on voit bien que c'est trop tard
donc c'est pas possible puisque après
deux premiers sets ont fait dames et
maintenant ça devient une partie de
plaisir la dame va ramasser des
d'options noir et en maths
d'accord ça bon je pense qu'on l'a bien
saisi donc des cinq d'entre eux voyons
ouais on a commencé par jouer h5
ouais le roi est venu verse option car
on avance le deuxième est donc là alors
là le roi la lawrence et après ils
reçoivent de feu à prendre le dessus
chaque don qu'il essaye de contrôler et
depuis on est ce que c'est possible
alors il vient sur la case f5 f5 dix
mois entre les deux gardiens de but
il est vrai jeu des prêts donc on en
choisit un à penser puisque l'aca ne
change plus rien à coeur en prend option
de l'es6 ont la bosse d'accord ça aurait
été pareil avec l'option qu'il faut
c'est en été c'est le seul à mettre
entre les cartels et là c'est plutôt
années voilà c'est insensé ravaillac la
pauvre à ceyrat valls et oui c'est ça
c'est ravaillac qu'ils ont que ces faits
car tous les ans mais 710 et je pense à
lui parce que c'est un anniversaire de
sa mort ravaillac bien voilà mon passé
cette précision historique
voilà nous pouvons voir que là une fois
de plus même même topo
on attaque le pion ouais donc les blancs
vont de l'autre côté on revoit le carré
de soutien il est ici bon on peut on
peut faire une comparaison avec le foot
c'est cesser le travail sur les ailes
c'était souvent on dit il faut les
ailiers on va sur les aides pour pour
élargir le jeu et finalement élargir la
défense c'est exactement ce qui se passe
we bought une comparaison comme les
autres mais on peut aussi voir ça comme
un contrepied au tennis contre hope you
tennis était en cours
finalement on peut pas l'être on ne peut
pas les tous les côtés donc ici c'est
exactement ce qui se passe c'est à dire
que le roi vient aussi s'attaquer le
pion on avance
la deuxiéme naret il continue à tenter
de garder contrôle
oui mais là suffit d'en avancer un leroy
obligé de revenir l'art ici élèves alors
on prend un vrai plaisir on avance
l'autre et ça va être très très simple
alignés donc là on reprend un peu cet
exemple on était à égalité de matériel
de pions liée contre deux pions pas
s'éloigner
et là ils peuvent en finale est plus
fort parce que effectivement commis sont
éloignés ils sont éloignés du roi
finalement aussi ils vont éloigner le
roi et le roi va pas pouvoir les arrêter
en même temps donc ça chez fo fo lequel
faut faut que vous quand vous allez sur
sur diagonale vous prenez votre temps
vous revoyez ces exemples ils vont vous
servir tout le temps tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps non mais ça ça
paraît un peu fastidieux et vous verrez
petit à petit qu'on va vous trouver des
exemples où il ya des superbes
combinaisons parce que là on vous montre
la base mais tout revient à ça oui c'est
à dire que finalement ce qui ce que vous
voyez là est assez simple à comprendre
vous l'aurez compris très vite
par contre ce qui est plus dur c'est de
l'intégrer complètement à sa façon de
penser aux échecs
ce qui fait que quand on commence une
combinaison complexe qui aboutit
justement à ce genre d'opposition on les
évalue immédiatement et on s'est dit ça
gagne aussi c'est nul ce qui évite
d'avoir à calculer c'est en partie ce
qui ce commencerait à être vraiment
vraiment lourd en calcul donc là
maintenant ça va être intuitive vous
voyez finale de pions tuons pas
s'éloigner c'est bon pourquoi alors
c'est là qu'on va peut-être arriver à
notre exemple le plus compliqué bah
c'est à dire qu'on peut si on sait ça on
va essayer de créer un pion pas
s'éloigner
voilà voilà maintenant on va revenir un
peu avant voyez vous c'est aux échecs
finalement ça c'est là où ça sert de
connaître les fin parce qu'on sait que
sega on sait que ça gagne par dans mon
sexe également c'est que ça gagne donc
c'est que ce gâchis
voilà donc nous arrivons dans une finale
de pions donc cette fête ça va de plus
en plus compliqué c'est à dire qu'avant
c'était un contre 0 ensuite trois contre
deux
deux contre deux et cette fois ci trois
contre trois il ya toujours de plus en
plus d'options alors ici voilà une
position qui a l'air a priori nul
puisque il ya deux rois et trois pions
pour pour chaque conte on se demande
presque qui est mieux dans cette
position alors réponse premièrement les
blancs ont un avantage l'espace et ça
c'est important puisqu'ils ont des pions
qui sont plus avancées et que ces deux
là sont plus avancés que les deux pions
noirs
pourquoi c'est important de plus annoncé
c'est simplement parce qu'on est plus
près de la casse de promotion donc dans
très important à regarder on reprend des
petits trucs parce que chien il faut pas
faire travailler votre mémoire c'est on
regarde l'espace si on a un peu plus
d'espacé que l'autre c'est souvent un
peu mieux la position des rois un
laurent l'a vu un an tous nos exemples
le roi est une pièce maîtresse pendant
toute la partie mais très importante en
fin de partie puisque souvent justement
là ils risquent plus d'être matés donc
il peut il fait quelque chose mais ça
c'est une précision importante qu'on
aimait ma fenêtre encore c'est
effectivement le roi devient une pièce
forte en finale déjà en finale option
particulièrement déjà parce que c'est la
seule pièce passe donc pas ce qu'il peut
revenir en arrière et surtout parce
qu'il ne se fait pas mater en tout cas
c'est des cas extrêmement rares endroits
au final option moi j'ai on peut
peut-être aussi
on a du temps la wii et loi on a du
temps il yad'excellents bouquin sur les
finales j'en connais quelques-uns vous
avez le bouquin de samuel cher et chef
qui sait pas si c'est de chercher si je
suis sûr chelsea sait pas rychetsky
sécher chére chef qui oui et qui parle
réellement de ça avec des exemples de
finale de passage en finale et surtout
toujours une institué souvient il
insiste toujours sur l'activité du roi
en finale 1
sinon vous avez le caresse le cuir est
ce qu est un excellent bouquin ou le ou
le patch man oui alors le querrey s'est
un petit peu plus technique que celle de
l'imaginaire et les connaît en fait foi
il vous est plusieurs types de livres
pour les finales donc ça on va faire une
petite précision biographique mais non
parce que c'est important parce que ça
ça se travaille
oui donc vous avez un le celui que vous
voulez moi prendre de l'eau qui reste
pour commencer oui je crois qu'ils
étudient les finales plus
mathématiquement je tirais c'est à dire
c'est les finales de tours où tout est
forcé où il ya beaucoup de ces plutôt
calculatoire donc plus technique
évidemment la plus fastidieuse plus fort
c'est ce que tu as dit oui tout à fait
alors que l'autre le donc le fameux
chercher ce qui est qui s'appelle master
in the game
voilà lui il est beaucoup plus
tranquille beaucoup plus décontracté il
vous dit simplement ou mettre vos pièces
quoi faire ce qu'il faut se presser
comment est-ce qu'on va gagner les
finales en général ils étudient et
finale complexe avec des pièces
une heure c'est la finale de fouler
finale de cavaliers alors que carey
c'est plutôt les finales au tour qui
sont plus mathématique d'accord donc il
ya deux types de livres évidemment pour
commencer pour commencer à tirer à
s'imprégner de l'esprit des finales il
vaut mieux commencer par les finales
philosophique appelons les comme ça
celle où il faut raisonner d'une façon
plus tranquille c'est à dire se dire mon
fou serait mieux ici mon cavalier serait
mieux là plutôt que se dire il faut
faire ça ça ça ça et ça allait
s'efforcer et je vais gagner comme ça
puis c'est peut-être la bonne méthode
capable en qu'elle faisait comme ça et
bien si oui lequel faisait il ya
effectivement un bouquin extraordinaire
on va parler de casablanca qui lui
croyaient véritablement à
l'apprentissage du jeu d'échecs par les
finales c'est principes fondamentaux de
josé raul capable en cas on vous le
rappelle c'est le le champion des années
1900 1920 et c'était un joueur qui était
connu pour avoir une science des finales
c'était un joueur esthétique et il
croyait beaucoup au final alors on va
revenir à cet exemple
revenons-en à ce donc à ce dernier
exemple de la leçon sur les l'option pas
s'éloigner
que se passe-t-il inégalités matérielles
mais ici les blancs est un gros avantage
c'est que bon donc chacun actions
passées l'option de l'an passé est ici
alors que le tueur noir est ici donc
l'option blanc en fait est éloigné il ya
gagné comparer option noir qui est plus
centrale et ça change tout ça change
vraiment ou non l'idée dans un premier
temps ces deux créations passées ne le
vraiment le mettre en valeur le mettre
en avant expliquait qu'il est là on joue
le coup à 4 à 5
donc là en craie et en menace est bien
aux menaces tout simplement d'avancé une
fois de plus et d'avancer encore et
encore on las de passer à dan qu'il faut
faire quelque chose là il faut
nécessairement nécessairement réagir
plusieurs possibilités y aurait roissy
ce qui est possible il y aurait plus on
prend lyon donc on va commencer par
psion préemption qui le plus simple on a
fort prendre évidemment on reprend 1 on
reprend toujours en finale b samedi
dustin hoffman en finale il n'y a pas de
sacrifier d'options ça apparaît sa part
être un bon principe puisque juste plus
d'initiatives
il ya beaucoup de la pallice à nos
échecs mais qui font une autre peu tarte
à covè on n'a jamais gagné une partie en
abandonnant mais qui sont beaucoup moins
idiote qu'elles sont en aéro premier
abord donc ici le roi vient chercher
pions ça paraît logique
et maintenant on voit que le roi est
très bien placé ici on n'a pas envie
d'amener notions en pâture au roi ce
serait une faute
d'ailleurs nous pouvons regarder ce coût
à 5 à 6 ce qui est une faute grave donc
puisque après roye b 6 3 des 5 reprend
3,6
on ne sait pas trop mais a priori
a priori a priori je n'ai pas d'à priori
je pense que ça va peut-être gagner
quand même donc à l'écran d'accueil sont
ce que j'ai dit c'est un peu plus accros
baptisé un chromatisme autant prêt et
c'est effectivement pas une c'est pas
une bonne méthode ce n'est pas une
méthode
en fait tout simplement donc revoyons
dans cette position là plutôt que
d'avancer le pion tout de suite alors
qu'ils seraient mangés par le par le roi
noir et d'ailleurs c'est une bonne
méthode en juin coup droit les couleurs
roi ne changerait souvent sont des coûts
de repos permettre de jouer les coups de
pions de toute façon pendant toute la
partie si on peut vraiment donner une
règle ce sont des coupes compromettant
pas forcément mauvais mais
compromettants oui voilà
oui c est aussi dorfman qu'on va imiter
dès le coup de pions agit beaucoup plus
la structure de la partie
et voilà on en sort on se moque de lui
mon fond l'aiment bien parce qu'en plus
il a quand même beaucoup aidé les échecs
français en dispensant des cours
badji ray du débutant grand maître c'est
tout à fait vrai alors l'idée de ce coup
donc rouen b 4 c'est que ça donne aux
traits au noir donc ça c'est une sorte
de mini zoug comme on appelle ça c'est
exemple la scène interne compliqué quand
même exemple c'est bien de l'allemand je
ne sais pas ce que je sais moi je
faisais ce sens mais pas la routine ça
veut dire la traduction littérale c'est
très fort c'était à cause d'échec on
leur dit allez les règles et c'est
important de calais on n'a pas le droit
de passer au bridge on passe dans
beaucoup de on passe aux échecs on est
obligé de jouer comme au jeu de dames
d'ailleurs et parfois c'est souvent un
avantage le fait jouer mais en finale ça
peut être un désavantage donc ici on dit
ou noir jouer parce qu'il vous avait pas
beaucoup de coups et vous allez est
obligé de vous affaiblir votre avis les
éléments font faire une concession ici
puisqu'ils sont obligés de sedan levé le
roi de cette case
ils ne peuvent pas jouer deux pions
puisque leurs pions sont bloqués sont
chedjou droit et la 4c 6 sur laquelle il
se trouvait était la plus forte la
meilleure nos questions que j'ai de
partir par exemple en 17
maintenant évidemment on gagne du
terrain où le roi b5
alors là les noirs n'ont pas trop le
choix dans cette position et 6 arcelor
plomb ils vont se faire manger il faut
qu'ils bougent le roi et maintenant on y
va à revoir ses 6 on va commencer à
ramasser sion deux possibilités soit les
noirs contre-attaqué montant à 6 ce
qu'on va voir maintenant on vire à la
2ème plus tard là on prend le pion il
prend notre pions et maintenant mais on
a un peu la même méthode que tout à
l'heure ça qu'on a éloigné le roi
l'avantagé d'avoir un peu ou pas
s'éloigner sexuelle huang le roi adverse
qui doit faire attention et maintenant
on va foncer bas pour manger ce pion
voilà on va on va prendre le dernier
pion très vite vous voyez ya rien à
faire on l'a mangé regardez valiant
quand quelques coups techniques et fouet
loi que tu les expliquer un petit peu
parce que maintenant c'est difficile aux
échecs info jamais - redit ses résultats
il faut jamais croire que c'est facile
hein donc cette finale là on l'a déjà vu
dans la leçon de la dernière fois nous
agissons de vendredi 2
lundi dernier après roy f7 par exemple
ici il suffit d'avancer le pion et ça va
gagné très facilement puisque après
roger 6 on prend l'opposition prend
l'opposition donc là c'est vraiment un
rappel pour cette finale
ouais rouages suite on rêve c'est de
toute façon ils devaient choisir son
côté on aller de l'autre
maintenant c'est fini puisque on
contrôle les trois cases d'avancé du
pion il n'y a plus qu'à l'avant c'est
donc tout simplement une fois qu'on a
pris pioncer roi étions contre pions
royan contre roanne on sait faire il y
avait une autre possibilité dans cette
position là dedans c'était avant
d'ailleurs c'est la position ici trois
sets 3-6 on aurait pu se dire avec les
noirs ah bah tiens je vais défendre mon
cul rond je vais jouer roi ici et alors
là tout simple grand on avance notre
pions et ça ne va pas changer grand
chose puisque la sylvia ans s'est vite
et bien on va pousser notions il aura
plus de coups on va aller à dame
il vient donc en race est très
logiquement c'est la même position alors
qu'est ce qui se passe on va faire une
petite
analyse quand même de ce qui se passe
c'est que les blancs avaient un tueur
passé sur la colonne à il est noir sur
la colonne c'est au final dans toutes
les variantes le roi noir a été mangé le
pion sur la colonne a alors que le roi
blanc a été le manger sur la colonne ces
mets donc le roi blanc se retrouvent
mieux placé voilà puisque justement les
plus proches de curling et c'est
toujours pour ça que ça gagne dans cette
finale
alors on pour voir la position de départ
donc on reprend à cette fois didactique
ici égalité matérielle les blancs ont un
pion pas s'éloigner le pion à à gauche
oui un de l'échiquier et faut créer un
pion passer l'idée c'est de les grandes
règles dans les finales de pioncer
l'activité du roi oui et la création
d'un pion passé ces deux éléments très
importants 1 et 2 on va pas donner
d'ordres je voulais donner dans dans cet
ordre là il faut évidemment combiner ces
deux choses oui un peu il faut combiner
deux choses
moi je pense je donnerai plus tôt la
priorité à l'avancé du roi mais bon
c'est un avis personnel je pense qu'il
faut toujours un et le roi au plus vite
en tout cas le réflexe en finale s'est
amené le roi vers le centre ici on a
déjà notre vers le sens de la pression
départ donc deuxième réflexe ont créé un
pion passer au plus vite
on joue donc à 5 il prend on reprend il
revient là petit truc petite astuce l'on
voit que le roi noir et très très bien
placé il est sur sa meilleure case ans
et 6 ans gagne donc un temps en jouant
trois des quatre on le force à bouger à
ce délogée de cette case ayant 17 ans
gagne du terrain
trois des cinq bras cette rousse et 6 et
là comme d'habitude toutes les
conclusions vont être les mêmes on va
prendre l'option sur la colonne s'est
pendant que les noirs le prendront sur
la colonne la plus éloignée la colonne a
et donc on aura gagné cette finale
puisque on sera plus proche de la
dernière faiblesse qui donc le pion g5 1
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire un bilan tout
écouter avec
parce qu'on est passionné par les échecs
n'ont pas ce qu'il faut c'est il faut
vraiment faire donc en finale en répèt
faut faire très attention le bus et la
promotion c'est d'abord l'activité du
roi effectivement tout à l'heure je vais
faut combiner les deux
c'est d'abord l'activité du roi qui va
vous permettre de rentrer dans la
position création d'un pion pas ses
pions pas s'éloigner
et puis je crois qu'on nous fait signe
faut dire envoie faut se dire au revoir
alors elle doit bientôt et bien des
prochains à lundi prochain pour une
nouvelle leçon sur capel le thème de la
prochaine leçon sera l'opposition en
finale de pionsat sera une des dernières
sur les finales de pions donc chasser
leurs ouailles me gagner du terrain bref
un autre thème très important des
finales de pion à suivre dans des
grenats de l'alzon cherté les notes en
voir